welcome back to glamour and Filton
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by free angelic Queens the stars
of Charlie's Angels I love this film
choice angels you are high kicking
higher than sporty spice in this and
you've know that as possible
you're bringing that spice but one of
the things I love about this you were
dominating in a male world and this is
what we need in our lives right now
and I love that line in the opening
scene where they say to you Christine
just because a woman can doesn't mean
they should and that really grinded my
gears because I was thinking about the
everyday sexism we still face in our
society what kind of sex um have you
faced in your lives and how do you shut
it down when you're approached by air
gosh I think women have to kind of
realize and embrace that communication
is a hard and something that is very
unique to the female experience my
favorite thing about getting older is
actually realizing how to come across
and I feel like you know I've accepted
how tricky of a scenario that can be
compared to how I've seen men assert
themselves and communicate even on a set
so I wish I kind of didn't have to do
that but at the same time you know I
don't know if there's a certain delivery
that I've kind of grown into being able
to do because I'm like but if I was a
guy I would never have to do that so
that type of sexism on a set like women
and like you know watching Liz try and
talk to her crew and see very clearly
that there were times where it was like
people aren't really listening right now
say it one more time you know what I
mean like it's like and she's somebody
who I think is very good at that but
even though like it's it's something
that we all have to deal with yeah
exactly
I'm luckily lucky though I've never like
had anything like weird we have in our
office I would be talking about it you
would yes what's amazing is that people
often don't really question confidence
feel like it's almost the more you
commit to your own passion and and the
confidence and have confidence in
yourself to make that decision it's
almost like it it will make it easier
for you to stand by a choice that you
know you've made it in yourself because
you believe in it and to that it's
almost like talking about it is totally
necessary but at the same time do
it's doing better because because then
it you know there's always gonna be
pushed back for you know there are
people that feel threatened by this
because it's like what I'm that's not my
experience that you know what I mean
it's like hard to understand it also
makes sense because like even in the
very like brief like you know she's
you're 23 years old I'm 29
we live in such an insanely accelerated
growth period that even that like the
fact that I had my answer is like little
do the level out of us really changed in
last like ten years when we were up we
weren't talking it's kind of well even
the gaps the small gaps feel larger
that's what it is like even me and Ella
like there's certain things that I mean
we always joke around about how she
shows me how to do things on like the
social media something to take part in
social media wow I'm really bad no I am
like technologically inept I'm always
like what is it yeah and like a whole
day yeah yeah story because can you
remember a time you specifically like
asserted yourselves it made you feel
awesome
absolutely I remember one time I got put
in in the middle of a pool this is a
Power Rangers and they were kind of just
like and they didn't put any platform
and it was really and they put weights
on me I don't know what they were
excited to kill me and I remember like I
couldn't I was like no no no no no I was
like guy I was like I had to and you do
sometimes have to see you didn't let
them kill you I did not good she's a
she's a strong empowered woman she did
not first thing that like people love to
do and to be honest like I've never
really I've worked with a like one
female first assistant director and like
ours is great but like it's just the
sort of um Train of it all especially
manned by people that are men we tend to
be men so yeah sometimes it's a little
bit like it's just an awful feeling
being like the annoying girl who's like
being conscious like no no no yo you
know
one of the things about these characters
which I love is not overly sexualized
either they used to be very sexualized
characters these player characters and
it's kind of like so amazing to you guys
so liberated by that because you're
allowed to like check out a girl in the
gym and that's absolutely fine in one
scene how liberating was that for you
guys in that terms of sexual liberation
yeah it was honestly like refreshing not
to have to pedal like a love story
because even sometimes those are like
embedded and they like so irrelevantly
embedded into things that you're like
okay of course there's like this thing
with the guy okay great and you and it
you know um and while also totally like
unabashedly dressing like sexy and using
like kind of using femininity femininity
as like a bit of a weapon at times but
also something that we were like totally
allowed to like bask in a little bit but
not because we were performing it it
wasn't for other couples right yeah like
that I feel but I also yeah I also think
that like everyone's really sexy in the
movie to wake I like I wonder like zoom
yeah exactly it's just that we don't
have to like give it to you because also
picking up on that point you guys are
such strong role models like having a
strong body image as well because you're
very controlling your bodies and there's
it's strong it's powerful it's not about
being thin it's about being strong how's
your relationship with your own body
image change your life that's a really
good question yeah hmm it's kind of
impossible to be in this world to be on
social media to be alright and not like
get those Norman's so I couldn't sit
here and be like I love every part of me
every bit of all the rides pretty much
stoked with what I'm looking at but I
think you know like anything it's like
kind of training your brain a little bit
in terms of what you spend your thought
life thinking about yeah so thought
because our brains have been trained to
like critically assess ourselves in a
way that is oh yeah disproportionately
it's just you know yeah girls are crazy
they're all going like Oh like it's it's
yes and also having the space to so
whilst you're taking up time thinking
about that you're then have less space
to think about other things you know
and I think that's something for me that
I have to train my brain that when we
all get the thoughts right and then I
think it's what you choose to do with
them if you kind of go you know what
like let me just switch that up and then
you you chip away at it and then you get
to a point where it's not something that
you don't ever think you just don't
spend that time on it you know and
therefore it doesn't fester and become
and out out work itself in other ways
because it's also about body strength
it's about mental strength as well these
characters have you worked on your own
mental strength as people especially
with me like I am a massive over-thinker
like huge like I like to think of
options a through Z knowing that a is
only gonna only a is gonna happen yeah I
don't know whether I enjoy whether I
enjoy it or if it's just because it
happens but you know like now it's like
I know that I do that at least so I can
know that whilst I'm thinking about B
through Z I can just go I'll actually
meet these but I'm enjoying the process
of thinking about it anyway and turning
and shifting that instead of being like
ah like I need to worry about B through
that so that's kind of my journey yeah I
totally get you know what I mean and
then there would be other people going
with the alphabet I don't know like
that's what's so great about it is that
you know no but that's also I love it
it's fantastic
I think the point of as well that you're
saying there is it's important to talk
about there because talking helps right
and I'll be staying here today body
image tech mental health tip to tail
which I've been making it happen I know
girls thank you so much okay you're my
problem today
thank you yes Bob yes
[Music]